Fleet Admiral Akainu Kuma and Bonnie
jump into fighting action as the epic
fight between Luffy and kizuru also
takes place in this insane chapter
that's right we got gear 5 Luffy versus
a shockingly powerful kizuru as we're
about to get into so make sure to stay
tuned for that not to mention some crazy
long-running one-piece mystery reveals
chill the parking with it and smash that
like button if you enjoy one piece
videos like this one and want to keep
them coming make this the video you
joined the Knockout by subscribing you
can help us hit our insane goal of 2
million subscribers here on YouTube by
just clicking that one button thank you
if you did and now without further Ado
let's jump into It spoilers and all
chapter 1092 is called the Tyrant attack
in the Holy Land obviously referencing
Kuma as we'll get into now so the
chapter starts as mentioned with Kuma
reaching marijuana some guards appear to
stop him but to no avail since father
can't really stop Kuma as expected he
uses ursa's shock to wipe them out and
some Celestial dragons actually get
injured too obviously this does not make
the world government look good and then
hype limiters get broken when who but
Akainu AKA Fleet Admiral sakazuki
appears wow big and unexpected delivery
by Oda in this chapter where we actually
get Akainu about to fight as well when
we were already so excited to see
Admiral kizaru about to fight Luffy
obviously my money in this situation is
always going to be on Akainu versus Kuma
and I don't think this fight would be
especially long but crazy that we'll see
the fleet Admiral in action so
unexpectedly he's definitely one of the
top five guys you want to see in action
in the show Aquino asks Kuma what is he
doing here he thinks to himself what
would a doll with no consciousness like
Kuma be doing in the Holy Land of
marijua then as mentioned Akainu
actually starts to fight against Kuma
we're told by the spoilers that Akainu
melts part of Kuma's face and possibly
Kuma's leg too with May ego aka the
attack hellhound this was actually the
insanely overpowered move that also took
out a large portion of whitebeard's head
like it was butter a truly impressive
feat against the one called the
strongest man in the world and the one
closest to one piece so it's not
surprising that it can do the same
tokuma we're clearly seeing a pattern
here and I guess Akainu just likes going
for the face interestingly enough Kuma
doesn't really fight back or defend he
just runs away and then disappears so
this makes sense I think we all know if
it was a head-to-head to the death Kuma
would have lost so this was about the
best Kuma's body could do in this
situation but either way we got Oda
hyping up Akainu again here reminding us
of his power luckily kaido's final
flaming Dragon form showed us that Luffy
can now deal with akainu's deadly magma
without actually physically touching him
so I think even this matchup for Luffy
wouldn't be impossible for him to handle
at this point but before we jump to
Luffy and the Admiral he's actually
fighting now we get Celestial dragons
shouting at Akainu for failing to
capture Kuma it's also noted that
Marisha was food reserves are at a
minimum too we don't get into spoilers
how Akainu reacts to this and maybe we
don't see in the chapter but I can
imagine that he's not too happy with
these entitled and way weaker than him
Celestial Dragons It's moments like this
where you can really see why GARP
refused to get promoted if it meant
having to obey these dudes and having to
cow toad to them oda's done a good job
of making these entitled Celestial
dragons hateable but they're quickly
gonna get shocked by how hard even their
lives can get if they don't get more
Food Supplies soon before the Luffy and
kisuru climax we also get a flashback
that takes place after Akainu captured
Bonnie two years ago the continuation of
the scene from way back in chapter 595.
cool how Oda brought it back around
after so long if you'll remember it was
when Blackbeard left her to run away
from Akainu and then akenu came face to
face with with a tied up Bonnie and she
said you'll pay for this as makes sense
now they were talking about her dad Kuma
and Akainu told her that her dad
willingly underwent his modifications
either way I think she'd rather be in
his hands than blackbeards even if she
was mad with him like she was with
vegapunk and now we get the most high
part of the chapter and Luffy is just
not giving kizaru the respect he
deserves here at least not yet and he
will pay for it we see kizaru versus
Luffy gear for snake man not even gear
5. I mean come on bro if you fought
Luchi in that mode kizuru definitely
deserves it from the get-go we are told
that they fight during several panels of
the chapter and if the panels come in
before the video is published we'll show
those here too but it's definitely very
hype that we get multiple panels of such
an epic anticipated matchup we're told
kizuru has light on both of his hands
and blocks while Luffy's attacks with
his arms and it seems like both are
using Armament hockey which makes sense
they don't use any new attacks at this
point though sort of just feeling each
other out from the looks of it but then
Keizer decides to shake things up big
time kisuru flies very far away from
Egghead Island to charge his next attack
he says speed is power which makes sense
the more speed you're hit with the more
Force you'll feel kizuru flies back to
Egghead really utilizing his speed of
light powers and kicks Snake Man Luffy
with full force Luffy as we could have
expected gets punished for using gear 4
against kizaru he's blown through Vega
Force One and in the process the robot
is completely destroyed Frankie by the
way is still at the robot we're told we
can see two flashback panels of Vega
Punk showing Vega force one takizaru so
this Arc as I mentioned before is really
kizodu focused in many ways he keeps
getting flashbacks and we are focusing
on his internal struggles of fighting
these people who he knew from way back
when from vegapunk to santomaru two
you're about to see who else soon as
I've been saying we need to get either
him reaching a Breaking Point this Arc
or at least the justification for why
he's such an obedient character
completely following his orders no
matter who he's ordered to take down
shared backstory and connection or not
luckily despite this devastating attack
the Thousand Sunny ends up being okay
because it lands on island clouds and
now as I teased moments ago another
character from kizero's past gets in his
way this time it is Bonnie who attacks
kizaru kizuru can't help but remark
you've grown so much don't force me to
hurt too many people I know during this
Mission see this stuff is still on his
mind and he can't help repeating his
wish to not hurt those he knows but at
the end of the day though we respect
Bonnie for trying we know she is not
going to be the one to take down this
light beast and he kicks her and she
hits egghead's barrier kizuru then warps
to the middle of the control room in the
label phase right next to Vega Punk this
doesn't look good right now without the
Elder kizuru alone seems to be
dangerously close to completing the
mission however in the last epic double
page of the chapter giant gear 5 Luffy
appears from above and he's visible
since the control room ceiling was
already destroyed and furthermore he
grabs kizero with his giant hand fantasy
kizaru being David rather than Goliath
for a change Vega Punk Nami usop Atlas
and Edison are shocked and their
eyeballs pop out of their faces as we're
used to now when we see gear 5 but
kizuru has a normal face now this could
be just him in control of himself and
not being as surprised or it could be
hyping up his own abilities if you'll
remember law could overcome docu's
abilities with his own hockey so this
could be a sign that kizaru is
potentially skilled enough in hockey to
be able to counteract the effects that
Luffy's awakened tunifying fruit would
have on him that would be big praise
because even kaido was clearly affected
by the Tune Force either way if Luffy
could take down kaido then I'm sure he
won't lose to kisaru here he'll either
win or or successfully escape and I'm
hoping he does the former before he does
the latter at the end of the chapter we
get another big reveal the legendary
ancient robot AKA The Iron Giant that
was originally created 900 years ago
around the time of the Void century and
then who attacked Maurizio at 200 years
ago before running out of energy yes
that robot that even puzzled vegapunk
with its mysterious ancient power source
wakes up we finally get to find out its
actual power source its eyes power up
after hearing Nika's heartbeat so
somehow Nika or Joy boy and now Luffy is
the power source for these robots
specifically the heartbeat that even
zunesha seemed to recognize the drums of
Liberation this could definitely be a
game changer and I can't wait to see
what this robot will do now that it is
functioning again what's the first thing
that I want to do will it just pull
Akuma and try to attack marijua again or
as would make sense to me will the one
who woke it up Luffy in this case be
able to control it or at least get
assistance from it luckily we won't have
to wait long to find out since there is
no break next week people so we'll find
out where these insane Cliffhangers go
soon enough so if you're interested in
Luffy's insane mythical Zone Powers that
we keep learning more about and that of
other mythical Zone users then you won't
want to miss my all 12 mythical zones
explained in ranked video link on screen
right now like And subscribe to help us
reach that insane goal of 2 million
subscribers and I'll see you in the next
one